okay so the last Last of Us season one
episode is now out and throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
episode nine all the Easter eggs hidden
details and also discussing the ending
first up though I want to thank everyone
for rocking with me the last nine weeks
and we're sort of like Joe lanelli a bit
because I doomed the entire human race
just to get a thumbs up from you anyway
we start off the episode with a
flashback and this features a major game
Cameo out in the woods We join a
pregnant woman running and this is none
other than Ashley Johnson Ashley voiced
Ali in the game and here we catch here
playing her mother so far several big
actors from the game have popped up
including Tommy's voice actor as Perry
Troy Baker is James last week and
Marlene who shows up later on in this
scene there's also a hidden Cameo at the
end of the episode and one of the nurses
is played by none other than Laura
Bailey if you've played the second game
then you might recognize this as being
the person behind Abby and though she's
obscured by a mask it's confirmed in the
credits very cool Easter egg now Ellie's
mother is called Anna and she was first
mentioned in The Last of Us comic
American Dreams this featured alien
Riley and in it we learned a little bit
about Anna and what she did before the
outbreak and I worked as a nurse and we
know she and her lifelong friend Marlene
survived together when everything went
down worse and this Channel's views next
week all that we learned from the
backstory was that she died within a day
of giving birth to Ellie but here we see
it fleshed out with her running to a
farmhouse being chased by an infected
person we can see a big symbol for the
fireflies denoting that this is a safe
house and you can also catch what I'm
guessing as the Boston QC in the
background as we know this was
controlled by Federer and though we
don't learn why Anna's out on her own
like this it likely has something to do
with the infected perhaps they were out
on the road and then they were ambushed
and Anna ended up fleeing which could
have led to this due to them searching
out in the wild I think that this might
have been the road trip that they made
in order to get the qz and this could be
them arriving for the first time the
thing about Insurgent groups like this
is that Federer could scan for the
infected but they had no no way of
telling who was a rebel or a firefly the
sights still be allowed in so
potentially this is them just traveling
out of the city and then everything
kicked off along the way we know that
the area surrounding Boston's full of
infected too and that's my theory ton on
why she's out on her own like this
hopefully they address it on the HBO
post release podcast and if they have
then make sure you drop it in the
comments below now Anna locks herself in
a room and then she bursts out a
switchblade which becomes one of Ellie's
main weapons in the main game she
manages to kill the infected but
unfortunately during this she gets bit
as she gives birth the cordyceps
probably mutated during this moment and
this is why Ali ends up being immune in
episode 1 we saw infection times and due
to the bite being on her leg she has 12
to 24 hours left with her child Anna
names her Ally and after the title
sequence we jump to the Knight to see
the fireflies arriving led by Marlene
this group don't mind shunning
flashlights as infected don't actually
get alerted by them this was a big thing
in the game too and you did need to turn
it off when you when navigating around
them and Marlene goes upstairs to find
Anna holding a knife to her neck in case
she starts to turn she hasn't breastfed
her either in case she infects it and
she entrusts Marlene with her child also
the green jacket that she's wrapped up
in is what Ellie later ends up wearing
when she's older showing that
[Music]
Anna also gives her the knife and this
is something that Marlene passed to her
in both the show and game they also
mentioned in the American dream comic
that it belonged to Anna and Marlene
promises to look after Ellie however she
refuses to kill Anna initially but
realizing that it's her Judy she
eventually decides to this is very much
the entire point of Marlene's Arc in
this entry and we see how she attempts
to put the greater good above what she
actually wants to do though she swears
to protect Ellie we see how at the end
she approves the operation that will
kill her and create a vaccine the finale
has all the morally gray areas that the
game does and in that when you're moving
through the hospital you find some of
her voice notes talking about the
situation the pretty long so I don't
just want to spend ages playing them but
there are two recorders that very much
give her feelings at the time the versus
her coming back off the reveal that
Ellie needs to be killed for the vaccine
and she's angry that she keeps getting
tested over and over like this the
second is far more heartfelt and it's
actually addressed directly to Anna she
apologizes for breaking her promise but
says that she has to go through with it
because this could save everyone she
says that Anna and her daughter will be
reunited soon and also states that she
won't kill Joel because he's the only
person who may understand how difficult
his choice is like him the pair both had
to watch over Ellie but this choice to
spare Joel of course damns them all now
there's also some really cool imagery in
this moment and Anna ends up giving
birth to Ellie beneath an illustration
of a tree trees have a neural network
underground like the infected and Ali
being born under this carries the
symbolism that a network could spring
from her that saves Humanity this could
also be seen as the tree of life and
it's a really nice imagery to add into
the scene now you know I hate the next
guy bloody hate him but Ryan arably
ryanairy was chatting to him about the
episode through the week and he spot
that Anna sings the song The Sun always
shines on TV by A-ha Take On Me by the
band was played at the mall and Ellie
also had one of their tapes up in her
room Take On Me is also a song that
appears in part two and Ellie sings it
at one point in the game this video is
sponsored by hellofresh I'm not really
talking about this on the channel but
for about the last year or so I've been
a vegetarian used to love fried chicken
to miss steak was a mistake to me uh but
I decided to do it last year and so far
I've managed to stick to it however it
can be difficult to find food that
tastes good but hellofresh have made it
very easy by creating an entire section
on their website dedicated to vegetarian
meals I can't really cook either might
surprise you that so I thought sticking
to it would be hard but hellofresh have
made Meal Time Easy by delivering
delicious simple to follow recipes
filled with wholesome ingredients that
show up quicker than a heavy spoilers
video what's good is that you can also
mix and match things my wife and kids
they still eat meat um but you can
tailor every single box to fit dietary
needs within your household I've also
been looking to lose weight the last
three months as well and they've made
that really easy too March's National
nutrition month and if you look for The
dietitian wind tag on them any choices
you can get a meal for under 700
calories with a third less sodium hello
fresh is also 70 less expensive than
dining in a restaurant and with food
prices going up it's definitely an
option to keep those costs low plus
we've teamed up with them to bring
viewers of this channel a massive 60
discount with free shipping what all you
have to do is go to hellofresh.com and
enter the code heavys 60 at checkout
I've linked it as the pin comment it's
in the description as well you don't
need to look for just go down click the
link and it'll take you to
hellofresh.com and just enter heavy
spoiler 60 at the checkout for 60 off
and free shipping what you waiting for
go now go go thank you now from here we
Jam to the present and finally coming
off the back of the winter chapter in
the game they used every season to tell
a sort of self-contained story and we
had things like the tomian university
sections in the fall before Joel's
recovery took place over the winter the
final section took place in the spring
and in that they've added a couple of
extra sections that we don't get here we
began with Jill and Ali out on Highway
and the four more is the one doing all
the Talking for once this is where we
begin and we even have the camper van
that you go into in the game and get
supplies from similar to that Joel's
found stuff inside of it he tries to
shake Ali out of the deep feelings that
she has in the game she was very much
realizing that she was at the end of the
road and that things here were almost
over it is important to bear in mind
that Ali actually wanted to go through
with everything even if it meant her
death in the end this is why Joe lies to
her as you know she wanted her life to
mean something which is a line that she
also drops in part two I'll not spoil
too much of that but but little things
that helped betray her thoughts I think
are important to bring her anyway on the
highway Ellie also notices an advert for
a plane which the show sort of touched
upon when they came across a downed one
in episode 3. Ali said that she'd had a
dream where she was on one and after
going to the cockpit she realized no one
was flying it to me this symbolized her
realizing that no one actually had a
clue what they were doing and that the
adult she entrusted all along were as
directionless as she was when you're a
kid growing up you think older people
have everything together but when you
become one you realize they've got no
idea either Ali believed that people
like Marlene and Joel would lead him and
deal with things but this episode shows
that they're driven by Instinct and
their own desires now whereas we find
Ali sitting on the back of a truck the
game had a zoning out to an engraving of
a deer this was clearly her remembering
all the things that happened for her to
meet David and it calls back to the one
that she hunted during the winter
Ellie's also wearing a red shirt at this
point with Joel dotting a grayish denim
one which what both characters were at
this point in the game I've from here
you move through an abandoned quarantine
camp that was set up on the early days
of the outbreak before going into an
underground tunnel this was full of
infected including Runners clickers and
to blow as little trick for you though
if you sneak through and just stop it
you can actually avoid fighting all of
them and you just get at the end with
Ellie and it's all gravy baby anyway
from here the pair made their way deeper
underground and they came across a
tunnel which had a burst pipe allowing
water to seep in when trying to navigate
over a bus this sprung free and Joe was
trapped in it as it was carried along
with the water Ellie saved him but the
pair almost ended up drowning and with
her passed out Joel had to swim through
he managed to make it through to the
surface which is where he tried to
resuscitate her it's at this point that
the fireflies showed up in the show they
pop up just out of the blue but we'll
talk about that more as we get up to
that bit in the story anyway back to the
episode and we see Jill messing about
with a backpack on the ground similar to
what you do in the games when you're
crafting and checking supplies honestly
I think they really recapture the
opening of the chapter here with the
highway perfectly mirroring how it is in
the game now we also get a mention of
Joel teaching Ali the guitar in both the
show and game he had a guitar in that RV
you feel that breeze huh
I'll tell you on a day like this I just
sit on my porch
pick away my sex string it's all smashed
up but got me thinking maybe I should
find one I haven't played in forever
yeah once we're done with this whole
thing I'm gonna teach you how to play
guitar
in fact I was thinking maybe I could
teach you I bet you'd be great at it
all right
what do you say huh
you want to learn how to play guitar
we'll talk more on this super spoiler
section about how this plays into part
two but it's important to show how
Joel's regaining his Humanity he was
completely shut off from the world but
now he's becoming apparent once more and
showing interest in picking up a Guitar
again and showing Ellie his Hobbies you
also see a sign for Salt Lake City and
this was the location that appeared on
the map in the University you really see
the pair's relationship flourishing in
these moments with Ellie predicting B
for beat about what they're gonna do to
scout the area it's a great moment
between Mando and grogu and here we head
indoors before we get into the giraffe
scene in the game you ended up going
into the Logan James bus station
terminal which I always thought was a
reference to Wolverine as his full
name's Logan James Howlett if you're
from Salt Lake though and I'm I'm so
like a [__] then make sure you call me
a stupid idiot in the comments and be
like no it's a real place and it's not
named after Wolverine anyway they spot a
ladder and Jill suggests boosting Ellie
up in order to grab it this is a
mechanic that happens in the game and
you'd often throw earlier places so that
she could drop one down down now this
was something that he'd gone through
time and time again but they changed at
the Dynamics by having Ellie dropped the
ladder like what happens in the show
oh my God
damn it Joe goes up like four flights of
steps I'm not sure how long this
giraffe's neck is but this moment it's
ripped right out the game
[Music]
don't scare it
what are you doing it's all right come
here come on
[Music]
what are you doing it's all right
hurry up
[Music]
come on
can you hurry up come on
hey there
[Music]
so [__] cool
oh where's it off to
oh [__] cool
where's she going
come on come on come on come on here
come on let's go slow down kiddo
and that was done to show that there was
still Beauty in the world even though
everything had come tumbling down though
Humanity might be on its last legs the
rest of the animals that live on the
planet had continued to thrive giraffes
in the show and game carry a lot of
symbolism with them too and they're very
much meant to represent innocence Sarah
had a giraffe toy in her room the
characters passed one in episode two
there was one up in the kids room in
episode six and they popped up
throughout both mediums at several
points in spirituality a giraffe's also
symbol of Grace and overall they
represent patience in the game this was
you taking a breather for the first time
in a long while and here you just looked
over the herd and had a moment to relax
now from here they go to a different
part of the roof and we get a scene for
scene Recreation of what happens in the
game
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Music]
is it everything you hoped for
it's got its ups and downs
got adoption down
can't deny the view though
you can't deny that view
[Music]
is it everything you hoped for was that
everything you hope for
jury's still out
oh man
she had to know that view
[Music]
can't you know that
we don't have to do this
you know that right
they'll have to do this
I just I want you to know that
it's the other option
go back to Tommy's
they done with this whole damn thing
what do you mean what else are we
supposed to do nothing we just
Tommy's we forget about the whole damn
thing
after all we've been through
that I've done
I can't be for nothing
can't be for nothing
[Music]
now Joe offering Ali a chance to go to
Tommy is not really the thing that he
wants for her it's what he wants for him
he knows that once he drops her off at
the fireflies at the relationships no
more and he's gonna have to go back to
Jackson whilst she stays with them this
is his chance to become a father again
so he's giving her this option but he
ends up making the choice anyway at the
end when he goes full Rambo on everyone
Ali also says sheep Ranch
the Moon this is something that he
brought up around the campfire in
episode 6. this was the future that he
wanted for himself and we'll talk about
how this plays in a part two during the
spoiler section later on
have a spotless you [__] anyway Ellie
wants to go through and finish what they
started which takes them to a makeshift
qz Camp his two is ripped right out of
the PlayStation classic though we do get
two very different emotional moments
playing out in both both Santa and Sarah
and in both the show and game we get
Jill explaining what exactly happened in
the series he says it wasn't fedra
whereas in the game it was anyway here's
how the explanations differ slightly
this is ephedra thing no
Army but this place takes me back
that is right after everything went down
I ended up in a triage just like this
they put these places up all around
the first few days after the outbreak
and everywhere you look you just It's
All Families torn apart
whole damn world seem to have turned
upside down in a blank they had me and
one just like this with Sarah
no she was gone already is that after
you lost Sarah
yes it will
can't imagine losing someone you love
like that
losing everything that you know
I'm sorry Joel anyway in the game at
this moment early ended up handing over
a photo of Sarah to Joel back with Tommy
he tried to do the same thing and we
learned that he'd return to Texas and
had stopped by their old house which is
where he found it Jill refused to look
at it or acknowledge it and it showed
how much of a closed book that he now
was Ali revealed that she'd stolen from
Tommy though and here she attempted to
give it back to him he ended up
accepting that he couldn't outrun his
past and it showed that he'd finally
moved on from feeling nothing but
constant grief and pain in the show
though he talks about almost ending his
own life and reveals a scar on his head
was self-inflicted now this skull was
something eliased about on the road all
the way back in episode 3. she all said
that someone should at him and missed
and I wrongly assume that this scar was
from when the soldier shot at him in
Sarah Jill said that he wasn't scared
and that he was ready to do it and in
the game the character actually
discussed people that take their own
lives they came across someone and Ellie
says that they took the easy way out Raz
Joel said that it was never easy yeah he
goes further into it and says that he
wasn't scared and in fact he was ready
he just hadn't seen the point in living
anymore when Sarah died but he flinched
when pulling the trigger and he still
doesn't know why when we look at it he
lived the next 20 years with nothing
really to live for and that was all
until Ellie came along the ending shows
that he simply can't go through that
again and he doesn't care who he has to
kill to spare himself of that pain he's
also seen the worst in humanity and the
argument is definitely there whether
it's worth sparing one good person for
us like the last of us if you imagine
nihilists could say that Humanity
deserve what happened to them and gel
very much represents the Riley mine
state of wanting to spend whatever time
he has left with the person he cares
about ali then says Time Heals all
wounds but he says it wasn't that that
did it Ellie has saved him and in return
he does what he sees as saving her and
thus saving himself It's Kind it's kind
of picky poison on what version you
prefer over this or the game and you
know I'm a die-hard fan of the ladder
but I actually think that it worked
better in this show now the mood is
enlightened by some puns
apocalypse lipstick there's no two
apocalypse jokes like there's no
tomorrow
too soon
no it's topical a moon rock tastes
better than an Earthly Rock
oh I love this one moon rocks tastes
better than Earth rocks why because it's
meteor
meteor that's terrible that was actually
good what did the green grape say to the
purple grape
breathe you idiot
it's so stupid what did the green grape
say to the purple grape
breathing with it well the fun is
spoiled by a firefly flashbang might not
be a flashbang I'm not a weapons expert
and every time I get it wrong people
kick off so yeah if it's not call me an
idiot in the comments below and make
sure you get those comments up anyway in
this scene that's reminiscent of Sarah
waking up in episode one we cut to some
blinds flapping back and forth before we
find Joel in a hospital bed windows are
very important the last of us and one
was used on the menu screen with a
similar setup for this being used at the
end of episode 3. Joel initially
believes that he sees blood but this
then forms into a firefly shape or
shadowing what's to come now from here
we get a scene that Rifts in the game
with Joe and Marlene talking
[Music]
welcome to the fireflies
sorry about that
they didn't know who you were yeah
you're pretty hard
she's all right they brought her back
where's Zoe she wasn't here
not even a scratch she's mostly worried
about you
you came all this way
how'd you do it
I have five men whose only job was to
protect me I still almost got killed
do it
it was her
laughs
she fought like hell to get here
what is over
she felt like hell to get here she would
have been dead on day one
and it was meant to be
I lost most of my crew cross in the
country
I pretty much lost everything
the country
but I owe you
we always take me to her you don't have
to worry about her anymore we'll take
care I worry
let me see her please
I can't
she's being prepped for surgery
you can't
what the hell you mean surgery the
doctors tell me the cordyceps the growth
inside her has somehow mutated
our doctor
he thinks that the cordyceps and Ellie
has grown with her since birth
that's why she's immune
once they remove it they'll be able to
reverse engineer of ax
makes normal cordyceps sync the cheese
cordyceps it's why she's immune
but it grows all over the brain
cordyceps grows inside the brain
it does
find someone else there is no one else
listen you were gonna show me
take me to her you take me to her right
now
stop
I get it please you don't understand
they do
but whatever it is you think you're
going through right now is nothing to
what I have been through I was there
when she was born Joel promised her
mother that I would save her child I
promised
I knew her since she was born I promised
your mother I would look after her then
why why are you letting this happen
because this isn't about me
I'm the only one who understands
there is no other choice here
I have no other choice
[Music]
yeah you keep telling yourself that
[__]
March him out of here
he tries anything shoot him
welcome onto the highway leaving there
with this pack he tries anything
shoot him we also add in some extra
lines of dialogue explaining how and why
Ellie is immune as we learn in episode 2
the cordyceps work almost like a hive
mind with that being vast wires of them
underground this very much extends to
how they work with the immunity too and
they see her cordyceps as normal so they
don't attack a multiply these chemical
Messengers being replicated could end up
being a cure and this Moline sees elia's
array of light now there are certain
things that come with this and if you
ever get into talking about whether Joel
was right or wrong you'll run into
people who say the vaccine wouldn't have
worked anyway and that there was a
chance it could fail there's definitely
that possibility too though the second
game does make it way clearer either way
the Firefly is having this cure could
have completely shifted the Power
Balance on the planet and they would
very much become the rulers of Earth
deciding who got immunity and who didn't
they're as cruel as the rest of the
groups we've encountered and as we know
they completely hate Federer they're
also complete heads and who knows
whether they'd even be able to replicate
it at scale I think whenever I've played
through this section on the game as well
I've always thought that the big thing
Marlene didn't do that she should have
is let Joel and Ali say their goodbyes
as soon as she got into the hospital she
was pretty much scan rushed to surgery
and there wasn't that chance where Joel
could make his peace with what was
happening they wanted the Cure as soon
as possible and whether that's to gain
power or save people I'll leave that up
to you to decide now Marlene says that
she was there when she was born but
she's very much sacrificing her in her
feelings to do what she sees as being
best for the planet what I love about
the ending is that there's no right or
wrong answer and you can fully see Joel
as being the bad guy had people not
played as him or watched him in the show
then I think that would definitely be
the case too on paper this is a man who
stormed a hospital and used it as a
shooting gallery so that he could kidnap
a girl and lie to her about what
happened these aren't the Hallmarks of a
hero but I can also see why people don't
like Marlene either had Jill let them do
it they could have held the world to
rans awesome I know I don't think
stopping them from doing that was his
intention there are questions to be
asked now in addition for the show Molly
instructor guards to give him Ali's
switchblade and this carries a lot of
significance Anna gave it to Marlene at
the beginning and I very much view this
as her trying to get rid of the girl
she's gonna carry every time she looks
at it this item brought with it a
promise that Marlene's gone back on and
how giving it to Joel very much reminds
him of what he's fighting for and she
did try her best to be fair and she even
enrolled Ellie and Federer so that she'd
be far away from the fireflies still
though her immunity brought them
together Molly now sees Ali as being a
hope for Humanity the blade is of course
so he can survive but Joel's gonna to
remember her every time he looks at it
as well we get an added shot that also
wasn't in the source material with a
tear rolling down Marlene's face to show
how difficult this was now it is also
possible that she suspected Ellie was
immune due to the birth and this is why
she wasn't immediately shot when she
revealed she was infected we don't
really find out how Ellie ended up with
a fire flies but it's possible that she
went directly to Marlene after hearing
about her from Riley and the game Joel
was taken out by one God in the scene
however here is a scored by two but he
still manages to get the upper hand he
stops at a sign before he hits the
stairwell and this is so he can see what
floor she's on and then makes his move
by killing them both such a good moment
and he interrogates the god like what we
get here
[__] you doing keep walking the [__] are
you doing keep walking
I said keep walking
where is he operating room
I ain't got time for this
where top floor the far end
now he takes his knife back along with
his backpack and switches into cold
Terminator mode we talked about this
last week with the interrogation scene
there and how when Ellie's in danger he
won't stop at anything to save her
there's no line he won't cross no one he
won't kill and he mercilessly moves
through the Halls firing at people even
if they surrender this bit was so
intense in the game too when he pretty
much just worked your way through the
hospital killing everyone that you came
across I really think it's a beautiful
Montage even if it's horrific I got
goosebumps seeing this play out here
similar to game you eventually hit the
children's Ward and you can catch the
paintings that they had on the wall
which are perfectly recaptured in the
show we also have rooms after the side
and this is where you'd find the
recorders and so on like in the game
Joel steps through the main door and he
then sees Ellie about to be operated on
I won't let you take her
I won't let you take her now this
character becomes very important later
on and we do get some focus on him as
Joe leaves carrying Ellie he leaves the
nurses alive and hey you're a better man
than me Joel because I was smashing him
like the like button
now he ends up getting to the elevator
and in the game he's chased by soldiers
but I think it makes more sense to have
him just make his Escape without them
breathing down his neck it's very much
done in the game to keep up the tension
Raz here he's clearly internally
struggling with what's going on now the
ending of The Last of Us is something
that stuck with me since I first played
the game back in 2013. killing doctors
like this is clearly crossing the line
but you could see things from Joel's
point of view as he'd been playing as
him for the last 10 hours or so as Joe
leaves he carries Ellie out and this is
symbolic for a number of reasons it's
exactly the same as how he carried Sarah
at the start of the series and Ellie
very much represents the daughter that
he lost he also gets put in a similar
situation to how he was with Sarah at
the beginning whereas we have a soldier
standing with a gun drawn ready to shoot
them we see that Molina stands between
him and the life that he should have
Marlene tries to talk him out of it and
she says that if Ellie doesn't die for
something like this then she'll know
that die for nothing because of the way
the world is the infected could tear her
apart Raiders could kill her and we've
seen throughout the season how many
threats lie around Each corner she
always says it's not up for Marlene to
decide but that's very much the case
with Jill as well what about Moline
correctly says that they both know what
Ellie would do which is confirmed later
on in the story by the character herself
now just like in the game we get the
resolution of the scene playing
alongside gel and Ali driving out of the
area let's play these scenes together so
you can see how they compare can't keep
her safe forever
you can't save her
even if you get her out of here then
what how long till she's torn apart by
infected or murdered by Raiders
how long before she's Torn to Pieces by
a pack of Clickers
that is that she hasn't been raped and
murdered first
Maybe
but it isn't for you to decide for you I
mean for you to decide it's
what
you know it so what would she decide
look
you can still do the right thing here
even after what you've done
we can still find a way
she won't feel anything
[Music]
ah
what the hell am I wearing let's take
drugs are still wearing off all right
you're with me
take it slow the drugs are still wearing
off what happened
we found the fireflies
it was just the fireflies and then
turns out there's a whole lot more like
you Ellie
you
people that are immune
people that are immune it's dozens
actually
anytime a damn bit of good neither
dozens of them the doctors they couldn't
make any of it work
they've actually
they've stopped looking for a cure
taking us home
bill I barely got you out of there
[Music]
wait
oh
let me go
let's come after her
you just come after her
now an important addition here is a line
about Raiders attacking the hospital I
always wondered why Ali didn't question
why they got out of there so quickly
without saying goodbye but this light
helps to add why they had to leave
straight away it also means that if they
go back there they can see the bodies
and this lines up with the idea that
they were attacked by an unknown group
yes I don't know if they wanted money or
they wanted something more sexual but
it's a lucky thing I had my pieces your
pieces my gun
I started blasting well I don't see so
good so I missed then they ran away
anyway you guys all think I'm a hero and
I'll accept that responsibility
we see Joel mercilessly shooting Marlene
and her wound is a repeat of the last
time with her getting hit in the side
the shows just how far Joel is willing
to go and she's meant to be a
sympathetic figure In This Moment she's
clearly badly wounded but Joel isn't
willing to take any chances and he kills
her because there's a chance you'll
still come for Ellie again Marlene has
very much given up her Humanity in
deciding to sacrifice Sally for the
vaccine whereas Joe has found his once
more through regaining a daughter now
the car breaks down by the side of the
road and we get a similar thing to what
happens in the game Ellie looks at her
bite mark and she very much views this
as the thing that was driving her but
now it no longer really serves a purpose
Beyond protecting her from getting
infected Joel says they have a five hour
hike ahead of them which they joke about
managing and this is a call back to
episode 3. he also discussed having a
five hour hike then too and like the
game at this point he starts to talk
about Sarah and how the pair would have
been friends don't think I ever told you
but uh
Sarah and I used to take hikes like this
well Sarah and I used to hike like this
all the time
I think
the two of you would have been would
have been good friends I think you
really would have
anyway I bet you would have liked her
back
and we can see conflict with an alley
and she's clearly weighing up whether to
question Joel as he spouts off stories
about his daughter just like the game
they arrive overlooking Jackson but here
we see it carries the updated design
from part two with a giant wall
surrounding it the pair look over it and
we get Ellie asking the question in a
scene that's pulled right out of the
game not much further now
it's a little bit further now
hey wait
back in Kansas City you asked me about
the first time I killed someone
back in Boston
back when I Was Bitten
I wasn't alone and I got bit in the mall
I wasn't on my own my best friend was
there my best friend was there
and she got bit too
she got bit too
if we didn't know what to do and she
says
you can just wait it out be a poetic and
just lose our minds together we didn't
know what to do
so
she says
let's just wait it out
you know we can be all poetic and just
lose our minds together
and then she did
and I had to
I'm still waiting for my turn Ellie her
name was Riley and she was the first to
die
her name was Riley
she was the first to die
and then it was Tess
and then Sam
and then it was Tess and then Sam that's
not on you I know none of that is on you
you don't understand I struggled
for a long time with surviving but if
you just keep going you find something
new to fight for
maybe that's not what you mean
no matter what
you keep finding something to fight for
now I know that's not what you want to
hear right now swear to me
swear to me that everything you said
about the fireflies is true
swear to me that everything that you've
said about the fireflies is true
swear
all right
I swear
okay
this of course goes over Riley and the
line about losing their minds together
is a reference to this
it also cements the survivor's skill at
Ellie feels which is reoccurring here
once more Ellie is once more living
whilst people are dying that she could
have helped and she Bears the burden of
it she's very much wanting to know that
there isn't another side to it and that
all the deaths meant something Riley
Tess Henry and Samuel died so that she
could get to the hospital the lives were
very much wasted in her eyes because of
Joel's actions he swears that everything
he said was the truth and Ellie pauses
and then says okay this is a line that's
always stuck with me as she's not really
saying whether she believes it or not
she's just saying okay I will accept
that version of events rather than
contesting it or asking further
questions she's happy to live in this
reality where her father figure isn't a
monster in her mind she's going along
with it that he tried his best to get
her to the fireflies but Raiders
attacked and it didn't work out now did
he do the right thing well that's
definitely Up For Debate but deep down
he knows that it's not what Ali wanted
which is cemented by the fact that he
has to lie to her had it been what Ali
was really after then he wouldn't have
hid the truth and he doesn't want to
seem like a selfish monster in his new
Daughter's Eyes he wants to be the
father figure in her life that she's
been craving all along and he knows that
telling the truth will completely
shatter this illusion and this works
both ways as well with Ellie not so much
believing a lie but she accepts it since
playing the first game I've always
referred to it as being the Godfather of
gaming and that's mainly down to how the
ending plays out in that seminal film
Michael's girlfriend K arrives at his
home and his sister bear sin and accuses
him of murdering her husband Michael
denies all this and this is because he's
attempting to retain the idea in case
mind that he's a good man who isn't like
the rest of the family whether we end
with the Mobsters coming and clearly
treating Michael like a Mappy head the
doors then shut on her as she realizes
the truth deep down that's very much the
case with Ellie too and she's now going
on to a new life in Jackson with Joel
believing that he's is not someone who's
just doomed Humanity now you can totally
see things from Joel's side too and I
think that had anyone else been given
Ellie then we likely would have had a
different ending Marlene and the rest of
the fireflies were happy to sacrifice
her but the fact that Joe was someone
who never got over his daughter makes
him the worst person to be escorting her
he sees the similarities and eventually
comes to believe that Ali is very much
his daughter which is cemented by
certain things that he does he calls her
baby girl at the end of episode 8 and
this is a nickname that he also used
with Sarah Joel also glances at his
watch at several points and these all
happen in moment in which he sees
similarities in them are they just
playing soccer with Sam causes him to do
it and it slays throughout lots of
aspects of the show they did remove the
moment from the scene at the end in
which he does it too but it's an
important thing to bear in mind as it
was there originally Joel needs to find
a reason to live and it's also cemented
by the fact that you find something to
survive for when he lost Sarah he wanted
to give up and it attempted to end his
own life however he must have had help
deep down that things would work out
which is why he flinched he's now found
the thing to make him whole again and
he'll do whatever he can to keep Ali at
his side even if it Dooms The Last of Us
it's a chilling way to close out the
season and I'm so glad that they kept
the scenes the same it was perfect the
first time I saw it and I still think
that it's perfect now now that closes
out the episode and for the next part of
the video we're going to be talking
about the consequences of this and what
it leads to in season two or part two
but it's probably gonna be season two so
there are Major Spoilers here and with
the first season following the game so
closely I can't imagine that season 2
will follow the second game pretty
closely as well so if you don't want to
know what happens then I highly
recommend you turn off now heavy
spoilers ahead and I mean heavy heavy
spoilers like people will be mad you
still here okay all right well let's get
into the Super spoiler section you can't
get mad you promised you wouldn't
right so the first thing that we need to
talk about is the fact that Joel dies
early on in the second game he's killed
by Abby who we discover was the door of
the doctor that Joel kills in order to
take Ellie we learned that for years
Abby trained her body to be Perfection
so that she could track down Joel and
get Vengeance this happens as well and
along with a group of people she heads
out from Seattle to Jackson Joel saves
her from a heart of the infected but she
still ends up killing him which is what
sets Ellie off on a quest to avenge him
that's pretty much the plot of the
second game without getting too much
into spoilers but yeah Pedro Pascal
might not be along long in the second
season anyway the next thing I want to
talk about is the line about the guitar
and the RV party opens on Joe hauling it
and this is a very important item that
reoccurs throughout we know that in
between this pawn part 2 that Ellie
learns to play it and she picks it up
and strums away at several points in the
game the ending of it very much centers
around it and after failing to kill Abby
and being let go Ellie ends up living on
a ranch with her girlfriend Dina and
also her son this is a sheep farm like
what Joel said he wanted in the season
and with his added context it's very
much Ellie living Joel's dream we also
get references to the Moon comment with
a flashback showing Joel taking Ali to a
museum for her birthday they end up
sitting inside a shuttle and Bard and
with a helmet and headphones on Ellie
imagines going to liftoff now back to
the guitar and after Ellie experiences
constant PTSD flashbacks she ends up
leaving to hunt Abby down after Tommy
tells her where she was spotted aliens
of finding her in Santa Barbara
completely disheveled after being
captured by a group of slavers known as
the Rattlers she ends up saving her but
as she goes to sail off Ellie once more
gets a PTSD flashback and she forces
Abby to fight her during this fight Abby
bites off her fingers and though Ellie
gets the upper hand that she decides to
let her go this is because she remembers
Joel and she learns that she could
forgive him and thus forgives Abby too
anyway people kick off about Ellie
returns home to find that Dina has left
that she's left her some of her
belongings including Joel's guitar Ali
starts to strum this and she attempts to
play Future Days by Pearl Jam which is
the song that Joel played to her at the
start of the game because of her missing
fingers she's unable to do this and she
very much lost everything including a
piece of Joel in this quest for Revenge
now that closes out the game how we get
an open window some of the how the scene
with Sarah start in season 1. I also
imagine that the hospital scene will
return but we'll get this from A New
Perspective like what we did in the game
Abby rushed in to find her father dead
in the wake of Joel's Rampage and I was
actually surprised that they didn't at
least send to her in the final episode I
still think season 2 will play out like
how it did in the game but maybe they
just didn't have her cast yet or maybe
they just didn't want to have the
conversation around the finale being a
very very controversial one because Abby
is a very controversial figure the the
face model for her still gets sent hate
mail and stuff in yeah people are going
to be very mad I think anyway that's all
this spoiler Easter eggs in the entry
now with the last of us first season
wrapping up I thought I'd give my final
thoughts on it as a whole if you're
asking whether I think the gamer show is
best then I have to go with the former I
think the game is probably gonna remain
my favorite world time for most of my
life another would be pretty difficult
for the series to Top This how about the
series start off really strong and after
those first three episodes it crossed my
mind a number of times that I actually
thought that this was better than the
game the characterization changes cast
action scenes in drama worked really
well leading it to being such a strong
start however I do feel as we got under
the latter parts of the Season that the
formula became very clear and every
episode sort of slaughtered into us
being a new character having an
adventure with them and then watching
them die having crossed the board and I
think that the latter episode sort of
lost their variety though I enjoyed
episode six and seven I think putting
them back to back made it feel like this
story was dragging a lot and if you
compare things to how those moments are
handled in the game there's a lot more
variety it broke things up with the
infected and Raiders attacking whereas
outside of the ones that popped about
the end of each episode it didn't really
have those Dynamics there's so many
Stellar infected scenes as well that
didn't make the cut in the series which
I think is a shame because the clicker
moments in episode 2 are handled so well
I wanted to see this translated to
things like the hotel basement the
tripwire trap as they arrive at bills
the sewer escape and pretty much every
section of the game in every episode the
thing they tended to cut was the
infected moments and I think that's
probably going to be a turn off for
General audiences who are sold on this
being a big post-apocalypse show there's
probably people who've just seen the
series I think you know the game it's
it's probably going to be boring but
trust me if you pick up and play that
you'll understand how much was missing
they did clearly lean more in towards
the drama side of things and whether
that's for Budget reasons or not it did
pale in comparison to me I just felt
like someone the things I think of first
when thinking of the game were exercised
and this is all in favor so that we
could get more character talking moments
now saying that I think the last two
episodes really went out on a high and I
think in the finale especially was
really well done I was worried when I
saw the run time that it wouldn't
deliver but it really did and watching
Joel walk through the hospital like that
really struck a chord with me I knew it
was the wrong thing to do but I was so
glad that he was also doing it the last
of us is a complex show and though it
did filter at some point I think this
overall was a brilliant adaptation for
what a truly stellar game now if I'm
scoring it then the game for me is a 10
out of 10. with the show coming in at
about an eight some brilliant moments in
this but yeah to me it's at a high bar
early on dropped off a bit and then
picked up at the end so yeah I felt
slightly short of what I was expecting
and if you haven't played the game then
I'm sure you enjoyed it way more than I
did I did still enjoy it don't kick off
don't stop kicking off I'm just saying
that when the source material is so good
it's difficult to not be like well I
wish they did this you know what I'm
saying yeah and if you love the game I'm
sure you'll have sort of similar
feelings anyway season two next and uh
that's gonna be a very interesting one
to discuss we will be back for that
definitely but yeah huge thank you for
rocking with me for the last nine weeks
I know there's been lots of great
breakdowns out there doing really good
things um and what I've tried to do with
this to kind of differentiate them is
make this the obsessive Gamers breakdown
where we go as in-depth as possible
point out all the most minuscule stupid
things and yeah people who are obsessed
over this game I hope you've enjoyed
that too anyway I'd obviously love to
hear your thoughts on the season the
game and also if there's anything we
missed hope to see you guys back at the
channel soon and we're running a
competition right now and give giving
away the rocky 4K box set to 3
subscribers on the 15th of March all you
have to do to be when the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the show you pick the comments out
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers you want something else
to watch we've got another Last of Us
video on screen now can we forgive Abby
uh it's a big question and definitely
head over there right after this without
the way thanks for sticking through the
video thanks for sticking through the
last nine weeks I've been poor